[Music]
the funeral directors and morticians
Association of Nevada bringing awareness
to the community about ongoing violence
across the country particularly here in
Clark County the association hosting
their second annual Stop the Violence
Community March this afternoon Madison
Kimbrough spoke with organizers and
families about participating in this
year's event she joins us live in The
Newsroom with the story Madison yeah
while it's only in its second year to
stop the violence March held on the west
side of town had a tremendous turnout in
support of those families who have lost
loved ones due to acts of violence
I will continue to walk each and every
year that I have to not only for my son
but for all the other families as well
in support of them Emily Dodd mother of
Dwayne King Jr who was murdered in 2020
gathered with community members Sunday
for the Stop the Violence Community
March hosted by the funeral directors
and morticians Association of Nevada she
like so many others holding up signs of
lost loved ones objected to senseless
acts of violence across the valley and
with this being the second annual March
the event this year was bigger than ever
this year we've actually expanded and
we're working with the coroners
Department we're working with Metro
we're working with victims of crime
it takes a lot to even come and address
their loss and the fact that they're
championing for their loved ones to try
to help find a solution for someone else
I mean it's nothing but a beautiful
thing nine funeral homes across Clark
County participated in the procession
slowly making their way through the west
side of town near MLK and Kerry Avenue
with empty hearses while families
marched on mother Wendy Ennis lost her
son JJ to gun violence in 2020 and feels
like marches like these really help in
her healing process this is always nice
to know that when something traumatic
like this happens that you're not by
yourself
and I hope with the coming years that
this March gets bigger and bigger and
according to Metro murders across the
valley are down by 10 percent but from
what some local funeral homes have seen
there's still so much work that needs to
be done I'm going to say that I remember
up to 35 families at least that we have
lost young children young kids uh to the
senseless violence
after the procession in March a
reception was held at Christian Embassy
Worship Center in support of the
families in The Newsroom Madison
Kimbrough 8 news now in 2021 Las Vegas
has seen 152 cases of violent deaths as
of October 7th of this year that number
is already approaching 107 people
between the ages of 20 and 29 and 50
years old have been the leading
demographic connected to these violent
crimes